parle les acteurs du transport en panne
depuis des mois se sont retrouvés cet
après midi à l'ancien conseil général
sans le patron de la sotra vos hommes
qui refusent de venir mais avec celui du
groupement mosaïque qui inclut la sotra
vos amis et avec l'autorité martinique
transport à l'ordre du jour comment
sortir de ce conflit qui prive de bus
depuis plus de quatre mois certaines
lignes de schoelcher et saint-joseph
plusieurs hypothèses sont envisagées et
à la possibilité de faire une régie de
ce que dit le vice-président vos
victoires et à la possibilité de trouver
une société qui va les médias préfèrent
un service extraordinaire ou
exceptionnel pour permettre que les
personnes qu'on puisse commencer à
voyager en attendant que le fonds soit
réglée vous avez terminé
si on peut dire avec l'aso travaux mais
que vous espérez repartir et que notre
place aux travaux
la sono s'est terminée avec la sotra
vent parce que je pense que lui-même en
lui-même il sait très bien qu ils
travaillent la solution au problème de
la sotra homme serait donc de se passer
de la centrale les membres du groupement
d'entreprises mosaïque doivent se
rencontrer dès lundi j'ai entendu tout
ce que souhaite l'autorité délégante
sous tout ce que qu'indique l'autorité
délégante de même que celle
les éléments d'information apportées par
les salariés donc je m'en retourne vers
le gme pour une analyse en commun donc
il y a un certain nombre d'entreprises
qui vont prendre les décisions qui
s'imposent
ensemble et si les entreprises du
groupement choisi c'est au contraire de
soutenir leurs collègues de la sotra vol
alors martinique transports pourraient
prendre le relais et imposer ce choix
en échange l'autorité délégante a
demandé un certain nombre de concessions
aux syndicats
la balle est maintenant dans le camp à
la fois du délégataire la cft eu et de
des représentants des salariés la cstm
parce que rien ne s'oppose à ce point 1
le bus à haut niveau de service puissent
circuler
ils parlent de droit doré très soul sur
le tcsp
alors que on le voit bien les bus sont
neufs nous avons également dit que il
faut d'une négociation séparée avec la
société martiniquaise de navigation pour
régler le conflit sur le transport
maritime
une nouvelle rencontre avec tous les
acteurs est prévue mardi matin pour les
bus celle sur les navettes maritimes
n'est pas encore fixée